un llamado a la unidad para entrar en
una nueva etapa sin llegar a administrar
la acción no es administrar un país
introducir una serie de reformas como un
conjunto de las soluciones
presidenciales para la gente la acción
ahora debe ir de la mano de la unidad el
respeto consideración y la participación
de todos de la consideración
así fue la convocatoria del reelecto
presidente francés emmanuel macrón al
jurar el cargo comienza su segunda etapa
de mandato en un país visiblemente
polarizado después de las protestas de
los chalecos amarillos dos años de
pandemia que impactaron duramente la
economía y una primera vuelta electoral
que vio importantes avances de los
extremos a la izquierda y a la derecha
macrón es el primer mandatario en ser
reelegido en dos décadas el acto tuvo
lugar en el salón de recepciones del
elíseo acompañado por cerca de 500
invitados entre los que se encontraban
los ex presidentes en nicolas sarkozy y
françois hollande en su discurso el
presidente también dedicó unas líneas a
la defensa de los valores de la unión
europea
el contexto de la guerra en ucrania
este pueblo nuevo es diferente desde
hace 5 años y ha confiado en un
presidente nuevo un mandato nuevo los
tiempos que se abren serán los de una
acción decidida por francia y por europa
actuar para evitar todo escalamiento
frente a la guerra en ucrania ayudar a
la democracia de actuar para hacer de
nuestro país la gran potencia ecológica
el reto más inmediato de macrón son las
elecciones legislativas de junio en las
que la unión de izquierda liderada por
jean-luc mélenchon y la ultraderecha
encabezada por marine lepén aspiran a
quitar poder de maniobra en el
parlamento a renacimiento el nuevo
nombre de la república en marcha el
partido del jefe de estado que ha
contado hasta ahora con mayoría
parlamentaria